moi j'ai envie d'en savoir plus là
dessus qui sont ces jeunes d'où ils
viennent
patrick godet c'est une grosse année de
melgven pour vous parce que ça a
commencé avec les survivalistes oui ça a
été diffusé un mois avant le début de la
pandémie à l'humain qu'est ce que les
survivalistes vous ont appris et que
vous a servi pendant ces mois de
confinement les survivalistes ce qu'on a
rencontrée c'est vraiment des gens qui
se préparent à tous aux pays qui ne
parlait d'une possibilité de pandémie
avant qu'elle arrive ce qui nous faisait
quand même ce jeu là vous maintenant un
peu allégés là mais qu'il faisait un peu
sûrs et d'autres fois rendu dans le
camion
malheureusement on a vu que c'était très
plausible et son état actuel maintenant
at il dit l'oeil à la pandémie il
suffirait d'une autre petite affaire
pour que vraiment ça bascule de l'autre
côté alors c'est quand même fragile ça
m'a fait prendre conscience que on prend
tout pour acquis puis que la vie ici en
amérique du nord
il n'y a pas de problème y arrivera rien
de grave en découlent
il faut quand même repenser un peu
assommés et se dire poursuivrait qu'est
ce qu'on va faire je veux donner mon
adresse le souvenir ici chez moi
fait notoire votre rôle de yanni gourde
en titre et 31,6 copat devront marquer
votre carrière c'est important pour vous
aussi
mais est-ce qu'à l'époque je jouais
puisque à part vous receviez des
messages de téléspectateurs et
spectatrices qui ne faisait pas la
différence entre le comédien et le
personnage quand on l'a vu encore
récemment c'est arrivé avec
malheureusement pour caroline ça arrive
à caroline cet hiver jeune jeff smidt
jeu mais aussi l'année passée pour son
rôle d'holly appelle ça je pense que les
réseaux sociaux on le voit dans
n'importe quoi aussi dans tout ce qu'on
vit présentement ça du jeu ça apporte du
très bon puis du très mauvais du très
nocif pesos les gens faux froid que
manille à l'humus ont fait des
personnages ces pauvres est de mêler les
choses des choses personnelles ou de
deux passes et les commentaires sur le
physique des gens sûrs que ce soit un
homme une femme arrêtés c'est pourtant
beaucoup ce sport fois où j'ai arrêté
d'aller lire les commentaires de mes
soeurs et les commentaires puis
quelqu'un qui va me dire je laime poste
actuel n'est pas bon pour le trouble
avec ça les gens qui me disaient que je
t'ai que je le savais que c'est un
malade mental puis tout s'est passé d'un
coup tu parles
[Musique]
les ultra marathon c'est vraiment de vos
grandes passions et semble-t-il que vous
courrez de la maison un plateau de
tournage pour mettez le rythme est assez
davo regardant tendrement qui signent
pas ce que veut pas non plus avec plus
de mes trois filles
comment ça se passe concrètement mais si
je le faisais si je peux le faire je
vais le faire partir de la maison
d'arrêt tournée je n'ai à l'époque quand
je faisais destiné à fin des années 2000
destiné providence à radio-canada ben je
partais de chez moi à boucherville 16
kilomètres a laissé ce kilomètre revenir
16 17 le départ
et ça se faisait très bien je l'intègre
eh bien je partais dépendant de l'argent
de journée que javel 52 kilomètres par
jour sur par jour wayne je faisais pas
ça tous les jours non plus mais c'est
comme une paire de souliers par année
sont pas des vigiles pas compter des tas
de souliers jardé à une multitude à mon
père donald rheault à droite à gauche
sauf que c'est un peu difficile pour une
femme de savoir que son amant n'émousse
une eau en quoi la course à pied nourrit
votre métier de comédien lorsque ces des
vases communicants j'ai un peu
l'impression chant meilleure forme j'ai
une meilleure énergie jeu capable
d'attaquer des journées solide beaucoup
plus facilement je dirais que qu'à
l'époque où j'étais pas en forme ou
juste un fumeur ou j'avais peut-être
l'habitude de coucher un peu plus tard
parfois en ayant appris petit peu trop
d'alcool donc l'homme maintenant j'ai
mon équilibre et mieux je suis vraiment
je me sens plus en forme
comme je dis je capable d'aller travail
encourage capable d'aller courir sur
leurs dîners mondains qtc les bras les
il est plus présent
en 2020 vous avez publié votre quatrième
roman oui les chiens oui la littérature
aussi c'est une de vos grandes passions
dont comédiens coureurs écrivain aussi
comment vous voyez la littérature comme
envoyer votre écriture puisqu'elle
balance ça vous a plu
je te dis que j'aurais tempérament qui
est plus écrivain qu'acteur moi je suis
plus introverti qu'extraverti donc
d'être dans l'univers de l'écrivain moi
de me lever le matin dans mon bureau
tranquille tout seul à écrire pour moi
c'est cette part a dit j'adore ça je le
fais je me lève pour écrire je me lève à
quatre âgés qui 4 le matin à 7 à peu
près j'ai fait ce pour tous mes livres
et où trouvez-vous l'énergie vous dormez
combat je me couche quand même
relativement trop à dire le soir c'est
fini et je me sentais tranquille va vous
êtes à six heures par jour de sommeil -
regret je m'en tire bien et si je peux
faire un petit pas aux nappes à travers
sur la journée je le fais sinon ben j'y
arrive par l'est
partout ce godet je vous souhaite une
excellente année de m merci à vous aussi
[Musique]